[Musique]
je vous invite à un moment de
recueillement en mémoire il ya trop de
fois en france où des gens se couchent
devant les islamistes et devant leurs
complices maintenant ça suffit il est
temps de relever la tête et de mener ce
combat sans s'excuser de mener ce combat
contre l'islamisme
le président de la république prononcera
un discours il remettra à titre posthume
la légion d'honneur samuel pâtit les
palmes académiques aussi je crois oui
israël sera fait commandeur des palmes
académiques là aussi c'est emblématique
puisque c'est l'ordre qui va avec les
professeurs avec le monde de l'éducation
je crois qu'il faut frapper très vite
très fort dans plusieurs directions
d'abord je crois qu'il faut qu'on
interdise toutes les associations qui se
réclame soi-disant de l'islam n'est
qu'il ne condamnerait pas fermement et
publiquement ce film à la biec ces
terroristes
quand ils sont français qu'ils soient
punis et banni de la société jusqu'à
leur conversion sincère aux valeurs
démocratiques
quand ils sont étrangers qu'ils soient
choisir je mets du territoire de la
république
il ya un principe de précaution à
prendre aujourd'hui qu'est celui
d'expulser tous les gens qui sont
aujourd'hui de nationalité étrangère et
fichiers pour fondamentalisme islamiste
ça permettra à nos services de
renseignement de travailler sur une
masse considérable être beaucoup plus
efficace si c'était le retour de la
double peine
dans un courrier guillaume larrivé
demande au garde des sceaux d'expulser
les quinze mille détenus étrangers
les quinze mille détenus étrangers oui
ou non progressivement on verra on
pourra pas le faire d'un coup mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il faut changer
aujourd'hui les choses il faut aller
dans ce sens là aujourd'hui
moi j'ai juste un message à passer aux
politiques de tous bords qui la ferme
qu'ils la ferment parce qu'à un moment
donné
depuis des années tour à tour ils ont
été au pouvoir que c'est une passe et
pas grand chose ne pas oublier c'est
surtout monsieur le premier ce ne pas
oublier d'agir assez de renoncement à
ces de résignation et de capitulation
coupable
la république du pas de vagues c'est la
république qui abdique et qui au final
laisse passer les islamistes ils sont
passés
je ne nie pas cette fameuse logique du
pad vague c'est à dire faire en 5
journées qu'on étouffe les listes ça
bien sûr ça sans doute en partie
beaucoup existé à une certaine période
depuis que je suis là je n'ai cessé de
le dire et je le redis à votre micro
ce n'est pas la logique que je demande
et je le dis dès le premier jour de mon
arrivée je n'ai jamais été pour le pas
de vagues j'ai mis sur place un système
de signalement
autant il n'était pas signalé comme
individu fiché s ou comme susceptible 2
ja
non il n'y a pas de faille ça c'est la
réécriture de l'histoire et il est plus
facile après que pendant dupond moretti
s'est taubira pire voilà c'est le
symbole du laxisme judiciaire je vous
rappelle qu'il ya un mois un mois
il nous expliquait sur un plateau de
télévision que la france n'était pas un
coupe gorge que l'insécurité
l'ensauvagement notre société était un
fantasme
décidément toute occasion est saisi 1
cette période de crise pour nourrir la
polémique est à lier les contre vérités
les mots nous les avons eu le mal nous
l'avons nommé la stratégie je les
expliquer notre détermination est
entière
les actes seront là la république
on a besoin plus de 3000 amende
cependant ont été dressés 1 depuis le
début du couvre-feu pour dix neuf mille
trois cents contrôles réalisés
[Applaudissements]